newcomer martin perez making his red sox
debut today hoping for the same
explosion that he watched last night
hunter alberto steps in for the orioles
here's the 0-1
and a swing at a line drive left field
side and ticketed for the corner it's a
hit for alberto up to the wall hayes
races around second toward third alberto
on his way to second with a double so
two on two out and it's up to ronaldo
nunez first pitch coming nuna swings and
whacks one left field and deep headed
for the monster and off the bottom of
the wall near the scoreboard that will
bring in two a ringing two-run double
for renato nunez gives the orioles their
first lead of 2020. two down for
baltimore
got jammed big time there
devers can't make the play and another
run is in and that's the second error in
as many ball games for rafael devers
alex copp has won six of his eight
decisions at fenway park and career
versus boston he has been really good
one two
fastball perfectly located on the inside
corner at the belt strike three
cobb looks in kicks home and the one two
is on the inside corner called strike
three
alberto
doubled in the first inning scored a run
hits it hard to right center that's down
for a base hit
that will score a run
and move the runners to first and third
iglesias with a good swing fly ball
little left field that's down for a base
head
and a 2-2
fly ball here comes jackie bradley with
the dive
and his first spectacular catch of the
season as he left his feet to steal a
hit from alberto
alex verdugo makes his red sox debut
today
going the other way for a base hit his
first red sox hit into left field
that'll move moreland up to second base
so he'd like that baseball
[Music]
for a keepsake his first boston red sox
hit alex cobb back out for the sixth
inning
there's a rocket that one's pulled
that's a shot and that one's gone it
barely got over the padded fence but a
home run
a searing line drive and maybe that is
that spark as the red sox are finally on
the board
and cobb
is done
first pitch hell
drills this one down the right field
line and it's headed into the corner
this scores alberto they're giving the
send around to iglesias relay throw the
plate is not in time to run double for
santondar and the orioles who gave up a
pair in the sixth regained their
advantage of five it's 7-2
and in the bottom half of the ninth
inning michael gibbons trying to
get the final three outs another
3-2 from gibbons here's the pitch and a
swing and a miss strike three and that's
how the orioles seal their first win of
the season
[Music]
you